okay [ __ ] and we are doing we're
about to start them [ __ ] kind of people
just passing by the waters are y'all
stop right there I think mari appears to
be in order we can move along listen I
said what the [ __ ] off better not okay
well apparently that [ __ ]
figure out where I gotta [ __ ] go oh
you're hosting around here
that's sitting over there okay so parent
[ __ ] it and it's gonna kill those people
ready okay so now we're doing it Dark
Brotherhood oh [ __ ] my deck is wet
having a wet dream again I'm having a
wet dream again sleep well man [ __ ]
fish your warm dry and still very much
alive that's more than can be said for
old gray lad oh yeah half of Skyrim
knows old hag gets butchered in her own
orphanage things like that tend to get
around oh but don't misunderstand I'm
not criticizing it was a good kill old
crone had it coming and you saved a
group of urgent to boot but there is a
flight
problem what what's the problem you see
that little arity no boy was looking for
the dark brotherhood for me and my
associates granada kind was by all right
a dark brotherhood contract a kill that
you stole a kill you must repay okay
right now funny you should ask if you
turn around you'll notice my guest I've
collected them from my help that's not
really important the here and now that's
what matters you see there's a contract
out on one of them and that person can't
leave this room alive but which one go
on see if you can figure it out okay
make your choice I'll cut right there
for fun I can hear you talking out there
wait is this about that raid last week I
told which one now is that what's
happening let's be making things off of
me you get to walk away oh ho ho the
whimpering our day yes yes I can see how
you'd come to that conclusion
interesting choice yes
indeed for you of course and you've
repaid your debt in full I would like to
officially extend to you an invitation
to join my family oh yes the dark in the
south when questioned by the black door
answer with the correct passphrase
silence my brother then you're in and
your new life begins quarter birch I'll
see you at home whoever they have to
hide their there we go to funky wrongful
[Music]
very fascinating remember the sanctuary
is in the southern pine forest just
beneath the road and away from prying
okay
okay let's see here
where the [ __ ] am I
enemies there by
remove that [ __ ] was the Dark
Brotherhood sector earnest yes yeah
okay okay Margot Margot I don't you why
are you bet just don't you worry [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] this [ __ ] is hex rattle aah silence
my brother a [ __ ] always barking let
the kill that [ __ ] that was a stir that
Astrid where are you ah at last I hope
you found the place alright yeah I find
your place alright well what happens now
this as you can see is our sanctuary you
won't find a safer place in all of Sky's
yeah yeah yeah so get comfortable soon
my dearest I'm arranging a job ah but
one last thing a will hang out